hello I'm Jeff I'm sweaty we're the slow
mo guys we have been for many years now
we're in a quarry today not in my back
garden because this is going to go up
really high and we don't know where it
will land don't you want to litter the
neighbors guns gutters yeah exactly what
we're doing down there's a classic
physics experiment where you take some
of the coke out of here and replace it
with liquid butane fuel
I mean you turn upside down it shoots
off like a rocket because of physics
because of physics but I'll explain a
bit more of that yeah well learn about
that as we go shall we begin
yes excellent all right down compressed
physics lesson go there's a pretty cool
science experiment using the interesting
properties of butane because it is
boiling temperature is about zero
degrees C which if you're American I
guess is something 30 something
Fahrenheit it's basically when water
freezes think 32 fahrenheit 32
Fahrenheit okay and it's stored as a
liquid inside this cannon because it's
it's such a it's only zero degrees as
the boiling temperature means it's not
super high pressure in there and when I
release this nozzle here what's
happening is gas will come out initially
liquid but it's just gas and that's
because the butane is is vapor pressure
is coming up and letting the gas escape
or is if I turn it down like this like
when you're filling a lighter and you're
actually using the fuel what happen is
the liquid will escape rather than the
guest yeah like that it tastes nice
right and we're going to use that for
we're going to use that inside of this
coke bowl now I'm going to pour some of
this coke out and probably down to like
here-ish and when I put the liquid in
because the butane is less dense than
the coca-cola it will sit on top and a
little layer like that and it will start
boiling then and sort of vapor will come
out the top but when I turn it upside
down what happens is because the butane
is pretty much immediately boils because
it's got all the contact with the coke
which is warmer than the butane and
causes it to instantly vaporize which
increases the pressure inside the coke
can causing a rapid expansion of gas and
then it escapes out the bottom causing a
sort of rocket effect and this venturi
shape here where it increases the
pressure due to the narrowness of the
bottom of the bottle also helps with
that and you can actually do this with
water can you accept the effects aren't
as pronounced because of there's no
carbonation that's right you can do it
with
but with the coca-cola what happens is
the the carbonation comes out of
solution and that increases the amount
of gas in the bottle even more so you
get even more of a rocket effect we will
begin at a thousand frames a second in
4k and it's gonna bag this excuse me
viewers even though this is a
interesting science experiment
definitely don't try it at home the
bottle could fly up and hit you in the
teeth or the eyes and it's also
incredibly flammable okay ready yeah go
for it whoa whoa
flippin Eck I just went that was like it
was struggling at first and then they
and the guests finally admit it's really
wet okay playing back so it's it's all
about rapidly turning it over rather
than like slowly because it has to rise
through the coat yeah so I've let go
this point expected it to go it just
looks like it's flowing now well I don't
think there's any propulsion yeah I
think that's just gravity kicking in
yeah there's no I think there's anything
until then
then it's like you see all the butane
coming out that the earth is like it
time to meet it into gas the wavy lines
yeah your face like what a character do
I look like there with your mouth like
that like some sort of Muppet you know
the mother you know one of the Three
Stooges yeah so it looks like what
actually happened was the coke all left
the bottle pretty much and then it went
I think possibly for the next test less
coke more Butte
let's cook more Butte okay I'll pump up
the Butte ready yeah I got covered ready
go Oh some air time it really got some
hang time there didn't it okay I
honestly I with the Phantom I tried to
track it absolutely no shot there's no
way I'm gonna be able to do that because
it doesn't take off immediately either
yeah I didn't want to leave too soon
then when it goes up and it's gone yeah
liftoff here we go we know the size of
that actually
should take measurements of the size of
the coke bowl and then we can plot how
quickly that's moving that's a good idea
look at this look at this attempt to
track it nice work there bloody oh it's
hot under this bag huh you you and you
in the bag oh it's like a face order Oh
Johnson coats like ten degrees hotter
what ah put your head in that up that
bag you see what you think all right
nope now I don't fancy that you can see
it all just like whizzing down the model
oh oh here we go yeah I feel like
there's a lot of factors in play because
once it starts moving the rest of the
coke gets kind of slammed down into the
bottom and it's also becoming lighter at
the same time so it's like an
exponential thrust
good so far yeah pretty fun at least I
mean might as well try this isn't
absolute by Honda we have to like move
around there this actually stops it from
evaporating as much ready yeah over
there oh no I avoided getting wet until
then
like I'm proper slow takeoff compared to
the other ones all right I got
absolutely Niall aid just god I was like
let's go up there immediately airframe
oh the big fat ones are too slushy like
I can't like turn them upside down in
the right amount of time yeah like they
just sort of and I bet because it's
you're like you swung it around yeah
it's ready to go but the liquid is still
inflicting this way on it yeah and then
it goes up at an angle it keeps going
off to the side and splashing me oh I've
got a medium-sized one I can still do
with one hand I think yeah and I could
do it pretty quickly because it's
one-handed and I think it'd be a good
sort of compromise between the two this
could be the perfect size yeah here we
go that was the best one I think that
was great
and launch rocket pretty much all the
cokes now out you see that yeah and then
it just starts spinning like it's gonna
be up
yeah well it's like you need a really
long one yeah okay you wouldn't be able
to throw a coke bottle that high would
you know it doesn't have a million years
it's like we keep like a team rocket
like little lens flare that's good fun
that Alright fun not to be done indoors
of course probably not or a greenhouse I
actually like it when this science
experiments are sort of really fun at
the same time as you're learning
something that's happen it's an
exhilarating experiment yeah cuz it's
like a lot of build-up and it's very
sudden I thought it was gonna be more of
like an explosion like I thought it was
gonna be like slightly more risk of this
like burst and open or something like
that I was a bit unsure and yeah like
the first time I did it I was like woo
but then after that I was like yeah
actually it's like a gradual sort of
pressure build-up and it shoots off
because chignon you you got your
absolutely cake to coke oh it's the
thing is because it doesn't evaporate
and the sugars left
yeah I'm just sticky for the rest of the
day did you bring a change clothes
no I really should learn never I never
be she's like we packed everything into
this truck hopefully you enjoyed that
video feel free to subscribe
whack that Bell it doesn't make a noise
sadly but uh it does do a lot for us and
we have a second channel yeah see you in
the next video we found them all
absolutely yeah no hat again